the same people that were either silent
or encouraged or said they shouldn't
stop like kamala harris
574 riots in the summer of 2020 kaylee
mcenany uh the same party whose senate
leader is by name saying you won't know
what hit you
uh
not being chuck schumer against specific
supreme court justices
but yet they only care about one riot
they're not investigating any of these
other instances how's this going to end
up i don't think very well
yeah of course they're not investigating
because they simply don't care that's
the hard truth you know karine
jean-pierre the press secretary said oh
well this is democracy oh it's democracy
crane well pass along your address
please i'm sure you'd willingly do that
so people could protest at your home and
pete buddha judge you referenced him he
said you people are upset okay pass
along your address pete i'm sure you'd
love it if people were doing this at
your home meanwhile what happened at
cavanaugh's home was not a protest it
was an assassin who came to his home but
sean the only reason this is allowed is
because it's enabled by the media today
i googled biden condemning kavanaugh
assassination just to see if i had
missed something over the weekend if he
had condemned it well the headline from
reuters was this biden condemns action
of man who threatened justice kavanaugh
i said oh that's new when did this
happen must happen sunday monday
no that was a headline from june 8th
sean headline from june 8th that when
you read the actual words of the article
it says that his press secretary
condemned it though the headline says
biden did i can tell you this anytime
trump did not specifically denounce
something prior to my press briefing it
was not enough to have my words
president trump's would always follow
but that was not even enough the
headline from reuters would have read
president trump refuses to denounce
assassination attempt because it was
insufficient if his press secretary
spoke on his behalf these are the
different rules of the game and the
press enables the kind of violence that
we're seeing and the threats that we're
seeing when they enable a president who
won't condemn it if any of us ever gave
out the address of any prominent
democrat or liberal supreme court
justice i promise you it would not go
unnoticed and we'd probably all be
arrested that's how bad the double
standard is in our justice system today
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else